aha here we are again yeah let me think
about this for a moment yeah I think I
was successful with c4 against him
recently and I'm kind of curious if he
has changed anything there in this
approach clanton not yet okay mean this
is also it is a perfectly okay line for
black of course it's not like this is
some kind of some kind of fantastic new
stuff that I'm playing Black is fine
here and so in this opening but had some
good results against him so we'll see
how he how he fares Bishop d6 I think
it's what it's normally played rook b8
is a bit unusual because of d4 normally
okay let's do it
okay so 93 what is he playing then a 6
mm yeah it has a this is definitely very
Catalan like he's 6 and then he wants to
go b5 I guess hmm is there some way for
me to explore like that
I don't want to think totally crazy span
of time
play the normal moves yeah I was
thinking because I'm I have I usually
don't play those Catalan structures all
that well so I was thinking a little bit
there if I'm if I'm actually doing the
right thing
he definitely has more experience and
knowledge there however currently I'm
threatening rook t6
and then almost you can go back to like
Queen b6 and take the take the rook so
it's not a huge thing I still might do
it but Bishop a4 is the more serious
idea this is really a threat okay it's
not that easy actually for him here if
he goes so if I take it Bishop f4 Queen
to b6 it's there something it's there so
it looks it looks weird it looks like
there is something clicks takes Queen to
b6
I don't know if it leads to much to be
honest
okay I'm going for this now but I'm
really not sure if this actually helps
I was thinking 95 year actually in this
position but right maybe this one
certain in Knight to Knight takes b5
maybe this is something it doesn't
really care about it what is the thing
here I don't care I have Queen e3 at the
end so I'm winning a pawn right what is
he going to create I know it gets me to
okay I see a CSU it gets to be too but
this is still a better ending for me I
just wonder rook c2 on what is the best
way to do this technically
not sure here I'm always kind of have to
I'm kind of stuck to the rook here which
is a little bit awkward I try routed to
d6 here
now you can go okay okay it doesn't do
that
probably not
can i play this for the win here I'm not
sure about it I can also go a four here
immediately
how can I do this it's probably more
precise I have a five as an idea just
March the pawn um oh I didn't put I
didn't consider that why is that
possible
time warning hmm I forgot that yes I can
count one two before I can actually take
50 seconds okay
you know it's so objectively it's a draw
probably check check check check
no no no I'm blundering hot one that was
stupid
well what's stupid
I mean okay it really doesn't matter
because he will do it typical time flame
now I'm tired of the rope here okay yeah
there was one there wasn't I mean losing
name well whatever it's the thing if you
if you feel like and it's um it's going
to be the time play as so can you kind
of get an object a solid to try anyway
okay this is a draw but he will probably
not even take it I don't think I had a
winning position at any point I mean he
was just just struggling with the whole
game being worse but I'm not sure if I
was ever winning probably not
I mean he just took I know he just gave
me that phone and got this in return
this ending is this better provide of
course I'm not sure that I can I should
do something they aren't doing before
yeah maybe the the engine let's switch
on the
engine output it once tune it wants to
keep the queen's own but i was thinking
that the apron is dangerous engine plays
97 years but i thought i've thought here
i'm better but you know what I did not
see I didn't actually see that if he can
go b3 and yeah I don't think I can I can
do much this this King defy is got night
a for I am those those things so this is
not actually better for me this is just
to draw okay
I mean here as it turned out I I'm one
of the pawn it just took a while to do
so it's still it's still a draw the
position yeah I mean yeah this really
sometimes bad psychologically the moment
I think okay is going to do one of his
time place I'm actually blundering like
this yeah I can do I can just keep the
corn but you you cannot win no three
against two in this type of situation as
a complete draw and yeah then as I said
the moment I felt okay he was going to
do one of his time place I've landed the
rook just just a normal move just a
normal move continues to a draw but 24
seconds I don't manage 15 moves or
something in that so he's got one of his
wins in okay guys thanks for watching